this week on quadriga international
turmoil New World Disorder Russia's
annexation of Crimea has shaken the
international community the European
Union and the United States have
stressed they are united over the crisis
and are threatening economic sanctions
against Moscow the g8 group of major
economies has suspended Russia and NATO
has issued reassurances that it is ready
to protect its eastern members even
countries such as China appear to be
reconsidering their approach to Putin's
Russia world once hoped that Russia was
becoming an increasingly reliable
partner but since the Ukraine crisis
that hope has been replaced by anxiety
about a new Cold War your host this week
Ally Aslan hello and welcome to quadriga
Russia's annexation of Crimea has the
potential to plunge the international
community into a long-standing conflict
what then are the global and wider
ramifications of this Crimean conflict
to help us answer this and many more
questions I am joined by three experts
all who've been following events in
Crimea very closely
welcome to Mukesh Duma who's the senior
correspondent at the German daily debate
he is a renowned historian and has
written extensively on Russia and
Eastern Europe ramesh Jarrah is the
global editor of the news analysis
service IDN in depth news as well as
global perspectives the magazine for
International Cooperation is also a
co-founder and executive president of
the global Cooperation Council a
think-tank devoted to fair globalization
and global security and Judy Dempsey who
is currently a non-resident senior
associate at Carnegie Europe and the
editor-in-chief of the block strategic
Europe previously she she reported on
Central and Eastern Europe for the
International Herald Tribune The
Economist and the Financial Times
welcome to all of you on today's show a
lot to talk about so let's get right to
it judy Dempsey ironically this conflict
Russia's annexation of Crimea seems to
have a positive impact on transatlantic
relations President Obama just visited
Brussels and met with his EU
counterparts now the transatlantic
relations as we know went through
somewhat of a recent hiccups due to the
NSA crisis and so on so forth but
they've come together in light of this
Crimea and conflict haven't they man I
wonder have they in fact
and certainly on paper there's lots of
smiles and lots of nice rhetoric and
lots of nice words but actually there's
two three major weaknesses in the
transatlantic relationship one is that
Europe and the United States are not at
one in terms of how to deal with Russia
and Washington has imposed tough
sanctions and indeed Washington has made
all the running with the sanctions the
Europeans are quite ambiguous about
going on to phase 2 and phase 3 of the
sanctions that's the first thing
secondly there's lots of disunity inside
NATO as to how NATO should respond and
what kind of measures they will do to
enhance the security of the Baltic
States in Poland and the third thing is
much more fundamental much more in the
long term how on earth are the Europeans
Americans going to get the big trade
investment partnership off the ground
this is these are three big issues big
issues in deeper Mukesh Zuma
President Obama seems to remember if you
will in some some respect who his allies
are who his friends are in light of this
crisis in his efforts to isolate Russia
internationally do you think this will
have an impact long-standing impacts on
the transatlantic relations well there
that's the law of unintended
consequences that Vladimir Putin has to
acknowledge and the price for Crimea can
be very high how high we haven't yet
decided and it's easy to get into
sanctions and very difficult to declare
victory but compromise where do we want
to be in a few months time or god forbid
in a few years time where do we want to
be what is our when when when can we say
this is an equitable outcome some voices
and I find them very worrying indeed
talk about NATO extension to Ukraine I
think it's a madman
we should analyze how we got into this
crisis very carefully and it's not all
the blame on put inside and all the
virtue on the western side I think that
we have treated Russia as a weak
passive spent force not taking any
notice of sort of legitimate interests
of Russia and I'm not the only one to
say so I take notice of the fact that
presents case as exactly the same thing
Henry Kissinger say the same thing do I
understand it correctly then if you say
the Europeans or the Western world is to
blame for the Crimean Khanate oh not to
blame but we've contributed we went
sleepwalking is the 2014 term
sleepwalking into a crisis of which
neither the EU Commission had the
slightest idea nor did Putin have a
master plan to cash in it came while we
were going on and on and on
congratulating ourselves about the Great
Western message to the 19th century
power well this is this is terrible
error arrogance coupled with ignorance
because the rules of politics are as old
as history and they weren't invented
yesterday in Washington DC so I think
it's a fairly complicated thing
and I think the the the Russia bashing
is well-deserved but there should be as
sons in self-examination on the part of
Europe and Germany and others Germany is
least to blame angular America knows a
lot about Russia and the Russians and
the self-examination on the part of the
Europeans for a majora is or may not be
ongoing but let's pick up on the issue
that Mukesh Zuma put forth namely that
we have perhaps in the West and in
Europe underestimated our own course of
actions the President Vladimir Putin has
said many times that the NATO membership
action plan for instance is a threat to
Russian national security meaning NATO
is coming closer to our borders and we
will have to react do you think he has a
point do you think Vladimir Putin has a
point well certainly what we are seeing
now is actually the new great game of
the 19th century that time it was
Britain and Russia and now it is the
West
if you Club all the best together the
best European countries some form of
East European countries plus the United
States and I mean looking back at
history we had the first Crimean War
that 160 years ago then the Czar wanted
to protect the Orthodox Russians in
Crimea and against the Muslim Ottomans
Putin says he wants to protect Russians
against the fastest Ukrainians so it's a
kind of old game great game which is
continuing in a different kind of
version on the other hand I think if
transatlantic relations are only
dependent on the threat maybe a
perceived threat real or perceived from
Russia then I don't think there's
something well at work there's something
rotten in the state of Denmark and the
third point I would like to make is
that we we shouldn't forget as mr.
Osterman said we treated after the fall
of the Berlin Wall
after the the dissolution of the Soviet
Union into several states we went on
thrashing the wounded Russian beer we
did not take into account how it looks
like if when you were strong and
musculus and now you're lying on the
ground you don't keep on hitting I
started back to differ on that in fact
it is quite remarkable that Russia did
join the group of seven industrial
countries becoming the eighth and it
definely did the WTO negotiations and if
the the international order was opened
to Russia I mean nobody wants a hurt
Russia or an insecure Russia or Russia
with an inferiority complex that's the
first point but the second point is this
propaganda from Russia that the Russians
living outside the Russian Federation
are under threat and there's an open
letter in today's New York Times from
the Ukrainian Jews and there's a
thriving community they're criticizing
Putin for using such nasty language and
saying that the Ukrainians are
persecuting the Russians and this
community said this is simply not true
and this is a kind of propaganda which
is very very dangerous for other ethnic
groups as well
Russian and non-russian living in in the
former republics of the Soviet Union and
if Putin's going to use this kind of
copy gander where will it end
and where will it and indeed that this
is one of the main questions we will ask
but Mukesh Duma let's look at what the
US and the EU have used as a tool to
respond to Russia's annexation of Crimea
for one asset freezes and travel bans of
high-ranking Russian officials and also
the expelling Russia from the g8 now
making it more or less their [ __ ] to the
g7 is that an effective move no the
short answer is no I think disinviting
Russia from a very importantly very
important group
Club is this ingenious because that's
where you can talk and say Vladimir you
went too far we understand you have
concerns but calm down and we'll find
the fix and we understand that you
crying you have to understand that
Ukraine is not part of Russia and we
understand that you want a kind of
special relationship because of culture
and religion and a thousand other things
that would have been my proposition if I
had to advise the Chancellor I would
have said this is how you save save us
all from a major crisis continuing to
develop at high speed so an ineffective
course of action that breaks see I think
basic issue is that we are bogged down
and what I would call a culture of
conflict if not a culture of war what we
need is a culture of peace and that
involves dialogue especially when it is
tough times we have to talk to people no
in German you call it bundled ocean Iran
that was the policy during the cold
I died as a cold war bringing about
change by talking to people dialogue has
to be the real crux of the whole policy
that one adopts now going back there are
always you know in conflictive
situations the the subjective truths
they tend to bloat themselves and that
results in greater conflicts if I
remember I was at the Munich the g8
meeting in Munich when Yeltsin was
brought in into the g7 you see let's not
forget it that the rest and I mean it's
of course the legitimate right of the
West to try to exploit a weak situation
in Russia when Yeltsin came I mean we
know he was a drunkard and best wanted
to make the best use of his lack of
instead lack of stability and lack of
composure and they brought him in but
Putin is a different kind of person I
mean we know Putin's background so we
cannot
say that best has always been very
sincere about about harvesting what one
would would have expected a peace
dividend
there was no earnest attempt to harvest
a peace dividend well I beg to differ I
mean three years ago at the Munich
Security Conference they did the big
there was a there was an agreement to
reduce nuclear weapons I mean there has
been progress on the nuclear weapon
front this has been so important and you
know in Ukraine as well and the
Kazakhstan this has been a major
breakthrough of the post Cold War era we
can't forget this and as regards Putin
himself and I I must say I think the
successive German Chancellor's have gone
out of the way to try to have a
relationship with Russia and the
modernization plan partnership which
since Merkel came to office since 2005
they did persist with it they really
believed that through economic
modernization a partnership helped
gradually the political system might
open up it hasn't happened and so you
can't bash the West for not trying
because I really do believe that Germany
did try and I think there's a huge sense
of disappointment now among the
political elite that this kind of
special policy hasn't led to the results
that Berlin wanted and indeed that some
of the political is special in the
Western of course of course Germany is
special this is now changing indeed how
we have seen Chancellor Merkel deal with
Putin but I think you're absolutely
right this at the end of the day there
has to be a dialogue I'm cutting off to
high log radicalize the situation end of
the day I mean in NSA knows exactly what
the Russians are talking about the
Russian service is know exactly what the
Americans and we are talking about if
they are interested so there then there
needs a lot of communication being
activated yes dialogue from the start
you do you don't need to establish
dialogue with friends you have to
establish dialogue with competitors
agree with this and I think one of the
one of the big problems facing us even
as we speak
now is that the longer we postpone a
dialogue even on the back channels the
more and radicalized both sides become
her the more set in their ways because
they're a group of European countries
that want to dig in and want to be much
tougher and this is actually quite
dangerous what's what strikes me one of
the few things that President Obama said
during his speeches both in the hague
and brussels said that the annexation of
crimea is not a done deal it's not set
in stone because it lacks the
international legitimacy russia and
especially putin has come a bit too far
now to turn back has no hasn't he I know
I know how far President Obama is right
of course he has to say that again let's
go back to his table professor but he's
a law professor he'll okay fine but is
there any circumstance that any of you
foresee that Putin would abandon crumby
and offer indexing it and the base
introductory let's go back to his little
bit 1950 the public People's Republic of
China it took over Tibet there was a hue
and cry and there's still you and cry so
where is this over Danity serenity of
tea but there's nowhere that the Indian
troops had to march into Goa because the
Portuguese refused to follow the British
and say okay Goa is a part of India so
they had to march in to take over Goa
some of some countries in the West made
it Ewan cry but it's become a part and
parcel of the Indian state it hasn't
happened in in Kashmir which is a very
conflicted situation for last 60 years
now because there are three Kashmir's
one under Indian control the other one
and Pakistani control the third one
under the Chinese control besides the
three of them have nuclear weapons now
some of them some of the people today
they are saying well if Ukraine had not
abandoned the nuclear weapons
would never have dared to take over
Crimea and even my friend Pan ki-moon
says ah we have to be very careful that
people do not stop giving up nuclear
weapons if situations like this arise I
mean I I find it shameful for the UN
secretary-general to talk about this in
other words he's saying keep your
nuclear weapons you know otherwise the
world will collapse so there's a lot of
confusion so we are in a state of
disorder in a world which was supposed
to have become more orderly more
peaceful harvesting the dividend of
peace so we have to speak we have to
speak to each other and that's the only
way out if we don't then there will be
vested interests on both sides who would
like to escalate the situation make it
more serious and that would mean a
military conflict of course and I don't
think there'll be a third world war but
any kind of conflict that takes place is
a shame for the 21st century for the
political leadership of the 21st century
so everything must be done to come to a
peaceful solution and a peaceful
solution everyone is seeking and one
country in particular might play a very
crucial role here a country that hasn't
been much hurt from during the course of
the Crimean annexation namely China
what is China's position what is
Beijing's position visa vie Russia's
annexation of Crimea let's have a quick
look
xi Jinping visiting a medical research
laboratory in France this week the
Chinese president's first state tour of
Europe is a demonstration the China's
economic links with countries around the
world are becoming more intense and
Beijing's response to the Ukraine crisis
may be a sign that its trade interests
are causing a change in its foreign
policy - in recent years China has
signed major deals to buy ukrainian
wheat an essential source of food for
its vast population and Central Asian
countries like Kazakhstan which have
traditionally been part of Russia's
sphere of influence are increasingly
exporting their energy to China China's
decision not to bank Russia over Crimea
in the UN Security Council might be a
hint that Beijing's sense of its
international role is changing in
previous votes the Chinese government
always tended to support its huge
northern neighbor
while Judy's MC we just saw that China
abstains in the UN Security boat on
Crimea there were various
interpretations of this some said this
is actually uh in favor of Russia in
favor of Moscow some said no no this is
a slap in the face of Putin what do you
make of it I think it's a warning to
Russia and that I mean China is very
uncomfortable with what Putin did in
Crimea because China has its own
territorial issues as well just look
around and his relations with Japan for
instance and not to mention Tibet
not to mention I mean there's quite a
number of outstanding issues and a land
grab is certainly not what China would
support abstention I think was a signal
to Russia I think you've gone too far
wouldn't it wouldn't clearly veto but
this was our supportive but I think this
was a quite a shift for China this is
the first point secondly Russia is
important for China but China has so
many other bigger bigger countries to
think about economically if we have to
think of Africa but particularly Europe
in the United States so I think China's
seriously looking at its a short-term
and long-term strategic interests that
may actually go beyond Russia and Mahesh
Sharma President Obama and Chinese
President Xi Jinping talked about a new
major power relationship in The Hague
are we seeing a new alliance emerging
out of this Crimean car when you Beijing
Moscow this is this carries us back to
the Nixon Mao triangle with Brezhnev in
the Kremlin not looking very
intelligently so the interesting thing
is whether China a group abstained or
not wasn't all that important Russia was
totally isolated that was the real fact
and no China came to the help of Russia
which had mismanaged a
very major crisis and that's the fact to
remember and when the Chinese leaders
now in Berlin this will be high on the
agenda to understand what is going on
there are some tectonic changes taking
place and China of course doesn't want
to be taken for a ride by poutine
this is adventurism in Chinese eyes so
China goes for the long term
poutine stumbled into this crisis there
is no master plan for the crisis there
was no master plan of course Putin wants
to reconstruct somehow the imperial
space which doesn't mean annexing
everybody around he is afraid of color
revolutions he has a trauma of color
revolutions this is not what you have
learned to like when you are have a KGB
background so when when he saw 2004 it
was a personal crisis for his leadership
and only because the various
intelligence services in Russia secret
services in Russia couldn't agree on a
replacement that's what saved him that's
why he came out triumphantly so the
Chinese mindset is a global one and the
Chinese see that in a global context and
then Europe America Germany are very
important Putin sees the crisis as
something on the margins of Russia which
he thinks is a legitimate target for his
policies and we all hope that it's the
last target that China has to play a
major role in this and indeed Ramesh
chara China's famous Beijing is famous
for its emphasis on the policy of
non-interference in other nations
Affairs always at least verbally at
least verbally this is what Beijing
always resorts to when it's being asked
to take a position for instance in the
Crimean conflict how do you think this
will play out on the Chinese front I
would agree that China has a long-term
policy and in the soviet days
used to say that the Soviets have a
long-term policy as opposed to the West
I don't know how far that was correct if
that was correct then we wouldn't have
seen dissolution of the Soviet Union and
we wouldn't have seen nothing happening
out of this is the Commonwealth
independent states the Chinese I mean
it's it's a the largest populated
country in the world it has huge
resources and the Chinese have their
strong national pride and there are
different ethnic communities in China I
mean there are Muslims in China they're
Christians in China and so China has to
be extremely careful in whatever it does
when it comes to the international scene
and I think China is finds itself right
now in a much stronger position than
Russia does because it's also
psychological reasons China has not
dissolved as a state the Soviet Union
has dissolved as a state and this leaves
very deep impact in the mind and I would
think that apart from the the Secret
Service background KGB background of
poutine he is not in a position to to
look beyond today he thinks he should do
pick make aware of an opportunity which
is there and he doesn't think either
what consequences it might have if he
does not get away from this course but I
think that there's in Russia too there
are intelligent foreign policy makers
and they would not let things go as far
as that but I think West has to be very
careful you know first does the g20 and
Australia Australia has already come up
with a suggestion with the g20 get
Russia out of this which is absolutely
nonsense because if you have Russia out
of g8 fine
amidst
doesn't change the world but g20 or
bricks for that matter you cannot take
Russia out so that's where Australians
or those who who's supposed to be
pursuing the policy of the so-called
West they make a big mistake if they
make sense most made a very interesting
point about the existence of bright
smart foreign policy experts in Russia
but when people television presenters or
journalists or experts do speak out
against Putin's move of Crimea they're
sacked from the Academy of Sciences from
radio from the television so I mean this
if Putin as you say is not thinking of
the long term it's very short term well
the effect of this policy I think will
only change from within yeah if if we
continue pushing putting up against the
wall so to speak what is left but the
internal dynamics of Russian society and
I think it's too early to say this but
we mustn't forget that 50,000 people in
Moscow took to the streets two weeks ago
there was immense courageous act against
what Putin was doing in Crimea and
Ukraine they were standing up for
something essential something that we
forget was part of this crisis human
rights freedom of expression to have it
a strong civil society and accountable
structures
that's an underlying hugely complex
problem now taking place in Russia and
indeed Ukraine we haven't seen the end
of this by any stretch of the
imagination and they of course various
other international conflicts that are
directly or indirectly impacted by the
annexation of Crimea let's talk about
Syria here President Assad by all
accounts perhaps one of the individuals
profiting from the Crimean conflict
because the focus has been shifted very
much away from Syria hasn't it - Dima
well PR wise it's a blessing for Assad
what what has happened and also not only
PR wise but also in in terms of
realpolitik right
Assad gets more probably more support
from Russia and what worries Israelis
and I think rightly so is that there may
be very sophisticated weaponry now on
its way which will which could be a
game-changer in the Middle East far
beyond the Israel the Golan Heights and
the Hezbollah territory in southern
Lebanon this is beginning to have global
consequences there is no such thing as a
regional crisis anymore it's longer it
is long gone beyond that point yes I
completely agree with you because DOMA
and but Assad is is is in a very strong
position now and we have seen that the
diplomatic efforts have gone nowhere and
it's it's and of course it's interesting
is that if how this will affect proteins
relationship with Syria and indeed with
around because I mean there's no doubt
that in Washington the Europeans have
needed Russia to go along with with this
whole complex deal with Iran is this now
going to fall apart or the poutine is
sort of allow it around to now even
boost its support of Hezbollah and feed
in more weapons into Syria if this is
unbelievably dangerous what's happening
and it's not a single issue crisis this
is a complex crisis as Judy said and
Turkey another country that is watching
from the sidelines has a historic
relations to the Muslim and Turkic
community of the tatar community in
crimea turkey of course has its own set
of internal problems these days but it's
watching closely very much so
and I mean Turkey has had under earlier
on Prime Minister Dan has a very hot and
cold relationship with Putin and indeed
with the Iranians and the Middle East
and now we've seen precisely because the
international spotlight was on Crimea
we've seen Iran who's having huge
domestic problems over corruption and
other issues in escalating conflict with
Syria which she can ill afford actually
to have the spillover is
is it's not only dangerous that the the
region Middle East is even more
combustible and one little footnote
unfortunately I hope it won't be turned
into a huge one is the Caucasus I mean
what Putin is done in Crimea may
actually ignite what the cognitive the
Caucasus which is so unstable at the
moment and the West cannot afford to
keep its eye
just on Putin they need Putin to
actually consider the long-term
ramifications of what he's done but also
the international community's
responsibility and awareness of what's
happening in in their own neighborhood
it's actually gotten worse over the past
couple of months
Ramachandra de-escalation is what you
set forth as a very imminent step to
solve this crisis what would a
face-saving
option look like for President Putin how
could he get out of this mess and please
the international community millions all
the question of this Judy said it has to
come from within Russia and I'm quite
optimistic that things will change as
the pressure mounts within Russia itself
it's a land not only of Marx and Lenin
it's a non mass was a British guy but
it's not a land of Lenin and Trotsky
it's also tossed over ski so I am quite
optimistic that Russians with it will
take some time but I think what what the
West on West Emeco is not one how much
anything should also take into account
is to a whale of the channels of
communication which exist within the
BRICS and within the g20 the Russians
have in the sense the great game they
have been very much interested in in
Asia and the Black Sea and to the Black
Sea Bosporus and the east Mediterranean
so you can sidestep the Himalayas and so
that's something we have to keep in mind
and I think there is a great possibility
even India which is which has close
relations
with Russia as it had with the Soviet
Union before for historical and
geopolitical reasons is not very much
amused about the accession of Crimea
because it can very well think what it
means in Pakistan tomorrow says that
Azad Kashmir the independent Kashmir is
a part of Pakistan and indeed Chile's MC
do you think that Putin's attempt to
alter recognize borders will open a
whole slay of Pandora's box do you think
well other nations attempt to to do the
same follow him well the Pandora's box
is certainly open we just have to look
at the the instability in Transnistria
which is part of Moldova but its Russian
fact and in Russian nationalists have
done actually probably annexing this
this frozen conflicts all over in we've
got the nagorno-karabakh we have
Transnistria we have other issues as
well I mean this is the fear of the
Baltic states that if if the so-called
West does a record of recognise but
admit that Crimea is is going to remain
in Russia there's a feeling and among
some Western countries well Pearman
Putin's stop that goes back to our
initial discussion you know how are we
going to have a dialogue with poutine
I take telephone calls are sufficient I
wonder if each leader has actually gone
to Moscow and sat down with the Putin
who says you know what you want to do
with this what's your long-term strategy
is there an exit strategy or safe
phasing for the west and Russia then one
has to find one is there any
circumstance
Mishima under which you can envision
President Putin become when once again a
reliable partner for the Western world
not in the short term in the long term
what are the options we have a lot of
fish to fry and we have to do it
together from the spread of nuclear
weapons to Syria to Iran
- global warming their major problem
Russia after all it's the largest
country on Earth around the globe we are
simply we cannot afford to continuously
send Putin into the corner where he has
to repent like ill advised the student
we have to work for that and we have to
what Kennedy did in the Cuban Missile
Crisis we also have to look for face
saving solutions not only for us but
also for the other side these are the
basic rules of negotiation and
international dialogue you the the
problem is not to love your friends the
problem is to talk to your enemies and
come to a common understanding and that
I think that over the last few months to
months we've moved away from that basic
principle I hope that anger in America
keeps away from that thing that I don't
trust the EU bureaucracy I don't trust
the advisors of about Obama he is
lecturing like a Harvard professor to an
undergraduate while the situation is
terribly complicated and of course Putin
didn't just march in he took the the
trouble of pretending that there was a
democratic element ninety-five percent
that was of course fictitious but maybe
half of the population is really was
really for the annexation so we when we
when we look at the future we'll see
more of that model this kind of playing
with democracy pretending that it's
democratic not just brute force but a
mix of brute force behind and some more
persuasive acceptable math methods of
course which are tinged through the
force and in the background
it's called managed democracy I think
managed democracy and euphemism yes of
course it's euphemism one tiny little
point on this we mustn't
you wonder what would bring the
Americans or the Europeans and Russia to
the negotiation table because at the
moment just Vladimir Putin see any
interest in it the opinion polls are
soaring in his favor you've got huge
public support for this and those who
were some critics who are saying I don't
like Putin
but they've able to serve able to
separate their opposition to Putin from
the support from what he's done in
Crimea so I mean it's it's a poutine has
no reason at the moment to go to the
table unless of course the Russian
economy really suffers as a result of
the sanctions we know the history of
these best relations and particularly
Germany's relations with the Soviet
Union so we need people like eggwin bar
we need a gun bars last night there was
an interview on the CD F with the
Siemens chief who went to the to Moscow
in hand and also met poutine he was
grilled by a colleague mr. cleaver you
know I mean it was such an aggressive
way of asking in questions why did you
do that you know I mean this is again a
conflictive approach and so the idea is
if Siemens chief goes there and has an
opportunity to talk and that means
economic relations economic relations if
you strengthen them then you will change
also Russia
from within because there will be vested
interests they'll be stakeholders within
the Russia who would not like put in to
go out of control Germany has been
pursuing this trying to pursue this
policy for so long that's the
frustrating aspect of it when she died
Myers the foreign minister's speech that
he gave her a Catarina Berg in 2007 it
was the extraordinary speech of of not
idealism but you know the politics of
wish fulfillment look we'll help you
we'll do this infrastructure
modernization trains health environment
clean water everything and they really
believed that this would eventually
happen and this kind of us politic
hasn't worked it did during the Cold War
as a dialogue which is very important
but there's a feeling among
many Social Democrats that they have hit
a stone wall as regards this very
fundamental policy and they're not quite
sure where to turn now and that's the
varying thing for them well I couldn't
agree more but again we have to start
from where do we want to be in five
years time or in two years time and then
we have to tackle the crucial question
and one of the crucial question Crimea
is a done deal I don't I have no
illusions about it and if Putin were to
say tomorrow oh I made a mistake he
could not show his face in Moscow
streets that's the trouble relationship
but where do we want one to be in two or
five years time my answer is work for
the Finland ization and you can arrive
at that great conclusion for you for
Ukraine you can arrive on that
conclusion only through dialogue and the
kind of cutting off the loudspeakers if
you go on this point I should agree with
you simple and feminization of of
Ukraine means that Ukraine that Ukraine
joins the EU because Finland is in the
EU and NATO well no no that's another
story they're actually negotiating which
clearly clearly so much more to talk
about a fascination fascinating
discussion I want to thank you thank you
and clearly what has been become very
clear that this conflict has very wide
ramifications on the global stage I want
to thank you out there for tuning in
thank you again for a very spirited
discussion we'll continue this another
time looking forward to seeing you again
next week
for a new edition of POD Riga